no you don't like the virus why not i
can't have
sleepovers or have a playdate with my
legs yeah i miss um like all the
playground equipment
it's kind of better because i don't have
to do things like drama lessons which is
always good
i've missed out on a lot of social time
um and obviously it's like my teenage
years like this of the years i want to
be getting out the most do you like
rose the virus is naughty
yeah okay what do you know about the
virus
it's very disney
[Music]
i do miss lessons a lot because i mean
obviously we still did our work but we
do
get to like talk a lot during our
classes and
i make jokes that otherwise we wouldn't
have been able to make
a teamwork kind of children i at
dawn and i'm a teamwork i thai or do i
they'll go to dawn
and what do you do make sure you don't
get the virus
don't go to people's health as that
people have advisors yeah what do you do
with your hands
no only
i really really enjoyed college when i
first started the first year it was
i'd say one of the best years of my life
like meeting all my new friends
um and it's just not being able to see
everyone not being like college is
completely different now i lost my
auntie
in march at the very beginning um so
that was difficult and
obviously we then had to attend things
like her funeral which was difficult
because you're only allowed a certain
amount of people
and then people were having to be chosen
the family who was going to attend
well sometimes we baked like cakes or
biscuits and
things just like i helped put sprinkles
on them
and ice them our internet isn't very
good so
our school game is loads of sheets with
work on to do
it's a bit weird because my teacher
isn't there
my mum and dad can help me with it but
yeah it's still a bit weird
i mean i used to walk with my friends
every day
to school and back but now i mean it
must have been on months
well just under months since i've last
seen some of my friends
i get to talk to people like actually in
real life
but a lot of the night time i do get on
like a call with we all quite like
gaming so we all have a
minecraft world together but yeah we
just get on
sometimes a whatsapp call or something
else and we just talk to a lot
i don't have anything
miss elizabeth and eight so they're my
best friends
exactly is my best friend and i love
playing with him i gotta go to his house
and i really loved it with my friends
okay i'll move her a little bit closer
so i have my 18th lock down my family
made it the best they could
well we had like cocktails makers and
stuff like that so we were doing books
like that
um i also had like drinks over place
time with my friends but other than that
we haven't really i've gone indian as
well but other than that we've there's
not really much that we were able to do
i suppose i'll just have to do something
big next year
i hope that all corona viruses
is like completely gone like in the
future
because then we can do loads of things
like go back to school it kind of
worries me but i know that like
everything will end up well hopefully
everything will end up
well